Dr zakya how should the Muslims greet
each other on the Eid day and
furthermore are they allowed to say Eid
muak as far as greeting one another it
is recommended in the Sunnah that
Muslims should greet each other on the E
day because it's the day of festiv Etc
and according to Fat albari number two
page number 446 the sahabas the
companions of the Prophet whenever they
met each other during e day they used to
wish each other by saying
meaning may Allah accept it from us and
you because Ramadan is the month of
fasting where people
supplicate they repent to Allah subhana
wa tala they ask for forgiveness they do
duas so when the month is over they pray
that may Allah accept from us and from
you that's the best and authentic way of
wishing each other as far as saying is
Mubarak it is said more in India and
Pakistan it's a way of wishing each
other congratulation Mubarak means
something of blessing so ID Mubarak
means may be a day of blessing but it's
more used as saying congratulation so it
is not a Sunnah to wish each other
Mubarak but neither is it haram it will
come in mu category optional because
when you say something in English you
know that may be a blessing on you
there's no problem so it is optional but
the right way of wishing each other is
as the sahabas did
meaning Allah accepted from outside you
okay